JAMAL EASON: Good morning.
Welcome to Google I/O, day two.
Welcome to our session on What's
New in Android Development
Tools.
We are so glad you
joined us, today,
and are really excited to show
you all the great things we've
been working on to help
you make great apps.
As a reminder, we look
forward to your feedback,
so please feel free to fill out
the survey after the session.
As far as introductions, we are
part of the Android Developer
Tools team.
Myself, I'm Jamal.
I'm the product manager
on Android Studio.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Hello,
I'm Xavier Ducrohet.
I'm the tech lead for the
Android Developer Tools.
TOR NORBYE: And I'm
Tor Norbye, and I'm
the tech lead for
Android Studio.
JAMAL EASON: Last year, we
announced a early preview
of Android Studio,
and we're continuing
to invest in Android tools.
Since launching the
preview, we have
had thousands of active
users, we had great feedback,
and today, we're
glad to announce
Android Studio in beta.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMAL EASON: So Android Studio
now helps you develop apps
with all the great new
development models introduced
in the L developer
preview as well as
supporting Android
Wear and Android TV.
We'll show you a few demos
and some tips and tricks
on how to make you
more efficient.
As you heard in the
keynote, we also
improved Android Studio
to integrate Google Play
services and Google
Cloud services.
Lastly, with
Android Studio beta,
we have enhanced the Android
Studio Gradle infrastructure.
Building on top of
the product flavors
and build variants we
introduced last year,
the Android Studio build system
now supports multiple APKs
and supporting form
factors like Android Wear.
With that, Xav will dig
deeper into the build system.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Thank
you, J. All right,
so our build system
is based on Gradle,
you may be familiar
with it by now.
If you're not, our
strategy was really
to create a unified build system
so that whether you're building
from inside Studio or
from your CI server,
it's always the
same build, right?
And we wanted to
have a build system
that was extremely flexible,
that would-- as J said--
support the whole ecosystem,
whether you're targeting
a watch, now, or targeting
multiple APKs, a paid version,
a free version, different APIs.
So we wanted really
a lot of flexibility.
And we wanted, also, to enable
a lot of code reusability.
We heard a lot
from people saying
that they wanted to
have a lot of libraries
and split their code
into various modules.
And so Gradle is really
the core strategy for that,
but the biggest thing is
that we wanted that whatever
customization you need
to do, it would always
work inside the IDE.
So the integration
between Gradle and the IDE
is our strong focus.
So when we look back on the last
12 months since the last I/O,
we did a lot of
features and bug fixes,
a lot of-- around variants,
and things like that.
We did some performance
improvements,
and we focused a lot
on IDE integration.
And so it's no surprise that
our current focus is still
the same.
Variant support, again,
being able to generate
multiple versions
of the same APK.
A lot of customization and APIs
for you to extend your build,
create new plug-ins.
There's already some
plug-ins out there
that are built on
top of our plug-in.
We're really excited by that.
We need to focus a
lot on performance.
We know a lot of
you are not super
happy with the
current performance,
and we're doing a
lot of work there.
And we're, again, focusing
on IDE integration.
The IDE integration
is really important.
Today, when we were
announcing beta,
it's because we spent the last
12 months doing a lot of work
on making sure that the
communication between Gradle
and between Studio is as ready
as-- well, it's not really
ready, yet, but it
is very close, right?
And if you've been using
Studio for the last 12 months,
you probably have
had a lot of issues
when you upgrade to a
new version of Studio,
and then it tells you, well, I
need the new version of Gradle,
and you upgrade to that
new version of Gradle.
And then your build script
does not really work anymore,
and you have to edit it, and
it's really painful, right?
And so today, we're kind of
saying, OK, this is beta.
We are committing to being
a lot nicer to you guys
and making sure that
whenever you get an update,
it won't be as bad.
And we'll have
deprecation period of time
where we change
things so that you
have time to adapt
to the new version.
So let's talk a little
bit about Variants.
For those not familiar
with it, a variant
is really a way of
generating multiple versions
of the same APK, and there's
multiple ways of doing that.
The first one is
through a concept
called build types,
which controls
how your application
is packaged.
Is it a debuggable version?
Is it not a debuggable version?
What is its [? sine ?]
[? wave? ?] Is it running
ProGuard?
Is not running ProGuard?
So it's the typical
debug versus release,
but you can create
more than that.
You can create new build types.
Maybe you're
accessing your server,
and you want to have a version
that accesses your production
server, a version that
accesses staging server,
a version, maybe, that access to
local, on your desktop, server.
So you can really
control all of that.
The second axis is product
flavors, which really controls
what your application is,
and the typical use case
is paid versus free or any
other sort of different session
that you want to do.
And it's a very
flexible mechanism.
You can have custom
interface for each of those,
you can have a lot of
source code suppression,
and it's sort of
something that you
can use right now to do
multiple APKs that the Play
Store supports, like per density
or per ABI multiple APKs.
So for example, you're
publishing a game.
You're going to want to have
one version with the ARM code,
one version with x86 code, and
one version with the MIPS code.
Even though it's possible
to do it that way,
it's not super efficient,
because the flavors are really
meant to be very separate.
And when you
[? speak ?] for example,
ABI, what you really care about
is just the final packaging
to just have three
different APKs,
but everything else is the same.
So we're going to introduce,
very soon, a concept
called multiple
APK splits, which
is a much more narrow and
focused concept about really
just doing density
and ABI splits.
And the benefit of it is that
the build will be much faster,
because all the things that are
not specific to that split--
so anything that's not relative
to building native code,
for example-- will be shared
across all the variants.
We also added some features
in the last 12 months.
We added variant features.
So variants are
really a combination
of build types and
product flavor.
So if you have a
certain number of build
types and a certain
number of product flavor,
we're going to make every
possible combination of those.
There are some cases where you
don't want those combination.
For example, if you're
splitting per density,
and you're supporting
Gingerbread and ICS
on different APKs,
well, there was
no Gingerbread extra, extra
high devices, so you don't care
about that particular
combination,
so you should be able to
say, I don't want this one.
Don't build it, so that
you don't build things
that you don't care about.
Next, we improved a
lot of dependencies.
So when you have
product flavor, you're
probably going to have
different dependencies, right?
So for example, let's
say you're doing
a paid and a free version.
Your free version will probably,
maybe, be ad-supported,
and so you're going to depend on
the library providing your ads.
To do that, you'll
have a dependency
only on that version.
So the for each variant, we
combine all the dependencies
coming from the
different elements
like the main dependency,
the build type dependency,
you could have a
debug-only dependency
if you wanted, and then a
free-only dependency if you
want it, and we've combined
all of that together.
On top of that, we also
have different types
of dependencies now.
That's something that we
improved a lot recently.
You used to have mostly
a compiled dependency,
now we have a provided
dependency scope,
which is only used
at compile time
but is not packaged with
it, we your application.
We have a compiled scope,
which is the regular one.
It gets both used at compile
time and at packaging time.
And then we have a
packaging only scope,
which is called
APK, actually, which
is only used for packaging.
So you could
actually do something
where you link against
a particular version
of a library, but you
package a different version
if you wanted to.
And then, finally,
on the variant side,
we have new Manifest Merger.
So this is really a
very important part,
because when you
look at your variant,
you could have some-- for
example, permissions that
are very specific to your debug.
For example, in order to
have better crash reporting,
maybe you want to use the read
logs permission, which really
you shouldn't be using
on your final version.
So you're going to have
it manifest in your debug
build type that includes
that permission.
On your flavor,
you're probably going
to have-- if you
have ad support--
you may be needing the
internet permission,
so you only do that on the
manifest of your free version.
And then if you're depending
on some libraries coming
from somewhere, either
your own or third party,
those may also be
needing permission,
may be declaring activities,
declaring services,
and you really want to
merge all of that together.
So the old merger was pretty
basic and didn't do much.
It didn't do any
merging of any nodes.
So for example, if
you had a library that
defined an activity,
and you wanted
to reuse that activity node
coming from that manifest
but wanted to tweak
it a little bit,
you couldn't actually do that.
So it was really a big problem.
So the new one allows
you to really merge
nodes coming from other
modules, and to really
have control over the
merge, and to really
be able to do what
you want to do.
So for example,
here, what you have
is an activity that-- so this
would be in your application.
And let's say that this
particular activity--
and the way to identify,
here, is the class
name-- is coming from your
library, and all you want to do
is basically replace the label
with a different resource.
So here, you say, under the
label, you put the label.
And then you have this new tool,
replace attribute, that says,
just replace the label.
And we're very strict about
it, like you can't just
replace it without telling
us you want to replace it.
And that's because if the label
is not defined in the library,
you can set it in
your application.
But if, suddenly,
without you knowing,
the library defines it's own
label, it needs to tell you,
there's a problem, right?
You didn't ad it when
it wasn't there before,
but now it's there,
so you should break.
So we force you to explicitly
say what you want to replace.
Another feature we
added to Manifest Merger
is the ability to inject values
into it through placeholders.
The big use case, here, is
things that the provider
authority where it's very
dependent on our package name.
And we know that when you
have a lot of variants,
they can have all
different package names,
and then you would have
to, basically, duplicate
that provider scope in
each of those variants,
and that just didn't
really scale right.
So here you have a single
provider in the main manifest,
and you just inject
the final package
name for the given variant.
OK, so another thing that
we worked on variant is,
variant publishing, which is
really-- so here's the issue.
The libraries also
have variants,
and by default, they
have debug and release.
So of course when
in your application
you want a build for
debug, you kind of want
to use the debug version, and
that doesn't work currently
with Gradle.
And then when you
introduce flavor,
there's a lot of work that
needs to happen, there.
And so we're working on that.
It's not there yet.
There's some changes
that we're working
with the Gradleware company,
the company behind Gradle,
to make that happen.
But it's something that
we're very aware of.
I think it's one of
our top priority bugs
on our bug tracker,
and it's something
that we're focusing a lot on.
So things will happen, there.
Customization.
So we did, also, a lot of
work on helping you customize
the build script as
much as you want.
So we have a bunch of new
parameters here and there.
I think the most interesting
one is the BuildConfig, which
is a class that was
created automatically,
and that added a
debug version, so now
we automatically inject
the package name, which
is especially important when
it changes on each variant.
We inject the version
name, the version code,
we inject which by
variant, and which flavor,
and which build
type you're using.
And now you can even
inject new versions.
So it's very
convenient if you just
want to inject a few flags
that you want to use.
You can also do
that with resources.
It's very limited to value-based
resources, so strings,
integers, dimensions,
and stuff like that.
And if you want
full customization
at the variant level, we have
different SourceSets, also
Per-Variant.
We used to only have the
debug SourceSet, the flavor
SourceSet, and now we
have [INAUDIBLE] debug,
is a SourceSet that you
can use to do customization
specifically for that Variant.
So for example, here's an
example of a BuildConfig.
So here we define two flags,
FEATURE1 and FEATURE2 two,
that are both false by default,
and then in the paid flavor,
we override just the
FEATURE1 to be true.
So that way, if you
have some code that's
not really variant
aware yet, and you just
want to put a quick
switch saying, hey,
if I'm in that
flavor, do something,
in that other flavor,
do something else,
you can do it easily here.
APIs.
So we did a lot of
changes in the APIs.
One thing that you
need to be aware of
is that, as a
developer, you're going
to define your build
types and your flavor.
You're never saying, I want
a particular variant, right?
You only say,
here's my big types,
here's a dimension of flavor,
and the value you need,
here's my other
dimension of flavor,
and here's the version you need.
And from that, we do all
the combinations ourselves.
And I mentioned earlier, we
have that variant feature
to at least be able to
exclude some variants.
So to be able to actually
do work on a variant,
we have an API that, once we
create all those combinations,
you can go and query, go
and look for variants.
Actually, right now, you
can only loop on them.
We do want to have
a better query
API to be able to query
for a set of variants
based on-- for example, give
me the debug variance only.
But right now, you
can only loop on them.
And then you can do a
lot of work on them.
You can access all the tasks.
So you can create new
tasks for each variant
and inject yourself in
between existing tasks.
You can change some parameters
on some of those tasks.
The BuildConfig
things, all the things
that you can do
on the build type,
you can also access the
merged version of all of that
and do per-variant changes
of all of those parameters.
So there's a lot of work
that's been done, there.
And some of those API are
actually used by the plug-ins
that I mentioned earlier that
go and do those many [INAUDIBLE]
for you.
So we are super happy to have
those plug-ins currently exist.
There isn't that many of them.
There's maybe
like, two or three,
but they are already
providing some good features.
So there's an example, one of
them is an annotation process,
[? or ?] plug-in.
You just apply it, and then
you can do annotation process
on your code.
One other thing that it does is
that it creates some new code
for you based on the
annotation processor.
And so it's creating that
code into a new source folder
somewhere, and we need to
tell the IDE that there's
this new source folder that
you need to use, right?
So we created some APIs to be
able to have that plug-in go
and tell the model that
Gradle sends to the IDE
that there's a
new source folder.
And that way, any plug-in that's
generating some new Java code
can automatically be
recognized by the IDE.
And inside the IDE, you
have code completion,
and it all works, even
with the generated code
by third-party plug-in.
OK, so we have support
for Android Wear, now.
So Android Wear, you probably
saw the keynote yesterday,
and you have that new micro
app that you can run directly
on the watch.
And the way it's
delivered is that it's
packaged inside the
main application,
and Gradle will
handle that for you.
There's a couple
of extra steps that
need happen like creating
an XML file that contains
a description of what
this app is, and then
an entry in the manifest, and
Gradle will take care of that
all for you.
All you have to do is that.
So there's two options here.
The first one is you just
use the wearApp dependency,
and you just link
to another project.
And that works fine
if you use Gradle
to build the final release
version of your code,
because it's going
to, basically, code
into that other project, have
it built, take the output,
and package it.
So when you do the
release version,
Gradle needs to be
able to do the release
signing of your app.
If you don't do that,
then the second mode
is something you can use.
Which you directly
point to an APK.
Here, you would basically,
on your CI server,
ensure Gradle to
build your microapp,
do your custom signing,
and then create
a new job that inject the
output of the first job
into the second job.
I mean, here, I
put a basic path,
but you could inject
that through a property,
through an environment variable,
or something like that.
This is mostly done for release.
For debug, by default, it
doesn't package the app,
and that's because the
workflow for debugging
is more-- you deploy directly
to the app from Studio,
you deploy directly to
the phone from Studio,
and that works directly.
So IDE integration.
So I mentioned that earlier.
We have an updated model, right?
We did a lot of
work to make sure
that the model sync works a lot.
And we're going to
keep working on that.
We have improved
sync, so sync is
when we send the model
from Gradle to the IDE.
And we have done
a lot of work also
on improving the
overhead of the build.
There's still a lot of
work to be done, there,
but we did a lot
of improvements,
so you should try it.
And also, we know that
there's a huge learning
curve about Gradle, right?
And so we are doing some
work inside the IDE.
We have a project structure
UI, we have editor support,
and we have a lot of
link checks to help
you deal with
creating Gradle stuff.
So performance.
We know it's very critical.
We are looking a lot at build
versus incremental, right?
Incremental is the
part that, really,
we worry about from when
it's inside the IDE,
and we did a lot
of investigation,
so we kind of know exactly
what the bottlenecks are.
And those bottlenecks are--
there's really three of them.
The first one is
project evaluation,
which is really a problem when
you have a lot of modules.
So we see people with
like, 200 modules,
and it takes a lot for
Gradle to really load
all of those projects and
start knowing what to do.
And we're working, again,
with Gradleware to-- they're
working a lot of work, there.
So we know exactly
what's going to happen.
Incremental supporting tasks.
It's making our tasks
be more incremental.
So APT's not incremental.
Dex is not really incremental.
So we're working
on that as well.
It will come in the
next few months.
And then finally,
task parallelization.
It's mostly important
for CI server
when you build a
lot of variants.
From inside the IDE, you
build only one variant anyway,
so it doesn't really
matter too much.
OK, and then finally,
the road to 1.0.
So we just announced
beta today, saying,
this is going to be a lot
more stable from now on.
We're not saying there's not
going to be any small breaking
changes, but we are going to
be a lot more careful, right?
The bar has been raised for
changes to not break you guys.
But in time to get
to 1.0, we need
to finalize that IDE model,
that exchange between Gradle
and Studio, so that
you can upgrade one
without having to
upgrade the other one.
And DSL is the format
of build.gradle.
We don't want to have you to
rewrite your whole build.gradle
every time there's an update.
And then finally those
two other features,
variant aware dependency, that's
the whole debug [INAUDIBLE]
release for libraries
and the compatibility
with the other Gradle
plug-in is something
that we need to look at.
It's going to have some impact
on the internal infrastructure
of the plug-in, and
we want to make sure
that those destablizing
features happen sooner rather
than after 1.0.
OK, and with that,
I will turn to Tor
who will give you
a tour of Studio.
TOR NORBYE: All right,
good morning, everyone.
On the tools team,
we like to think
of this as [INAUDIBLE]
sticky note.
So if you're coming
from Eclipse,
the first thing you'll want
to do is import your project.
So you just invoke
import project,
you point to your main
application project,
and then you tell us
where you want to put it.
And the reason for that
is that this is not
so much an import
as a migration.
So in Eclipse, we didn't have
libraries with resources,
so you had to do
this, you had to,
for example, drop in
all of ActionBarSherlock
with the source code
and the resources,
because that's just
what you had to do.
So in our import, we try
to reverse that process.
So when import is done,
you get this summary
where we tell you
what we've done.
So you can see
that, for example,
it founded a .jar file that
it recognized as a dependency,
so it just puts it in
the dependency instead,
and that means that you no
longer have just a .jar file
sitting in your file that
you have to worry about.
Gradle can check
this out whenever
anyone builds your project.
Likewise, it recognized
a source library project
with all the sources and
resources and it got rid of it
and just replaced it with
a simple resource, again.
And last but not
least, it tells you
how it remapped
the source files.
So you can see here that
it's moved, for example,
the resources and
the source folder
into this main directory.
So the new Gradle build system
has a much deeper directory
structure, and there's
actually a good reason for it.
So let me switch to a slightly
more complicated project.
So I'm going to invoke the
project structure dialog,
and here you can see I
have several flavors.
I have a free version
and a pro version,
and I have different
application IDs
so they can both coexist
in the Play store.
I have different
build types, and those
can also have different
applications suffixes,
so I can have them both on the
same device at the same time,
and dependencies.
So the whole point,
though, is that since I
have these different
SourceSets, I
can actually do per
SourceSet overrides.
So for example, I can
have a debug manifest
that gets merged in, so I
can ask for a mock location
only from my debug builds,
or in my beta build,
I can change a string,
for example, to say,
this is the beta
version of the app.
So that's why we have this
new directory structure,
but we do realize that it's a
bit inconvenient to work with.
So now I want to show
you a feature we're
working on that didn't make
it into the first beta build,
but it's going to help work
with these deeper directory
structures.
So it turns out that
you can actually
choose how you want
to view your project.
And so we're adding this
new Android specific view.
And when you invoke
that, you can
see we're putting all the build
scripts in one place, so you
can easily find them, all
the manifests in one place,
all the code in one place,
and my favorite part--
[APPLAUSE]
Wait!
Wait, you haven't seen
the next thing, yet,
because this is what I like.
So if you had any
nontrivial Android projects,
you probably had resource
folders that look like this,
right?
20 of them, the whole screen,
and you had to look for a file.
Well, look at the
resource folder, here.
It's flattened.
So for example, my
drawable folder,
I can instantly see that
I have a launcher icon.
It's shown as a single
file, but if I expand it,
you can see it actually have
all the different icons.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
So this makes it a lot
easier to find your files.
Similarly, in the
values folder, there's
just one value folder in here.
I can see, well, all right,
I have nine different string
files, I have two different
style files per version,
and I have a couple of
different dimension files
based on-- Anyway, look for this
in one of the next few canary
builds.
So that's the import flow.
Let me show you the
new project wizard.
So one of the things
we're doing now,
which is simple,
but kind of useful,
is we remember your
domain name so you
don't have to keep entering it.
So we can sort of carry that
forward for each new project
that you create.
And so on the second
panel is where
you choose your
[? MinSDK ?] version,
and we've added this
Help Me Choose link.
So when you invoke that, you
can click on the different API
levels, and we're showing
you the features that
came in that API
level, and we're also
showing a recent distribution
percentage for that version.
So you can help
decide your trade off
between features
and distribution.
So you can see, also, on
this panel that we now
have support for the
new form factors.
So I can add in TV.
I can add in Wear and Glass.
And as I walk
through the wizard,
I get to choose an
activity template
for each one of
those form factors.
So here is my TV activity.
We have a sample that we're
going to show you a little bit
later on.
Here's my Wear
activity, and there's
a couple of Glass activities.
So let me show you
the design time
experience when
you deal with Wear.
So here is a layout that
has been designed for Wear.
And you can see, they're showing
it with a square form factor.
Later this summer, you
may want to also try
to switch to the
round form factor.
So you can sort of see
what the layout looks like.
Or better yet, you can
show both at the same time.
So now, when I'm
making an edit, here--
let's see that I'm adding
a little welcome label
at the top-- this might
look good in square,
but look what happened
to round, right?
No good.
So this would need some
more visual tweaks, or maybe
a per-shape layout.
So speaking of
visual adjustments,
Android has had
bi-directional tech support
for a couple of releases,
now, and so we've
added support for right
to left text in the tools.
So let me open up a layout
that I believe is correct.
This one should working
in right to left locales.
So let me now
switch to this mode
where I can see
it simultaneously
in right to left mode.
So when I do that,
I can see my layout
left to right on the left
and then right to left over
here on the right.
And I can instantly see that
while the name and email looks
like it's OK, there's a
problem with the phone number.
So I could go and
fix it, but we also
have this refactoring
that will convert
your entire project called,
Add RTL Support Where Possible.
When I do that, it opens
up this refactoring
that basically goes through
and fixes all the attributes
in the correct way.
So let's just do
that, and you can
see that it now updated
my layout just to fix it.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, if you're
doing custom views,
you probably have to do
some work on your own.
But certainly if you're
using the built in widgets,
it should just work.
And by the way, if you're making
edits in the Layout Editor,
it should do the right
thing to begin with, right?
So I put a button
in the left, it
shows up right aligned properly.
All right, so let me
show you the Action Bar.
So if you look at the
Action Bar on the right,
here, up until this
morning, the layout editor
would only show you the
title of the application.
We just had some design time
hacks to put that in there,
because it's very
difficult for us
to know what the
activity is going to do.
But when we know the
activity, we can actually,
as you can see, figure out what
should go in the Action Bar
and show you those
icons right there.
In fact, I can even click
on the overflow menu item
and see the menu, and if I
click on one of the menu items--
sorry I clicked on
the wrong thing--
if I click on one
of the menu items,
it'll navigate to the
corresponding menu file.
[APPLAUSE]
So now I can obviously continue
to edit in the menu file
and see the visual
effects, there.
And we're hoping to have some
more graphical way of actually
adding menus soon.
All right, so let's talk
about the new material design.
So as you can see, this
is not material design.
This is Holo.
And the reason for that is
that this app has a application
theme and where we've
explicitly asked
to inherit from theme Holo.
So let me go ahead
and upgrade it.
And the way you
do that is to just
inherit from
Material.Light instead.
Quick tip, when you're
doing code completion,
press tab, not
enter, and then it'll
just replace the whole string.
So when I do that and I
jump back to my layout,
you can see it now does the new
L preview rendering correctly.
Now, if you look
carefully, you'll
see there was a red
underline, and this is saying,
this is not safe, because using
this theme requires API 21,
and you're trying
to support API 9.
So we now have a quick fix for
this, which basically says,
when lint says that
there's an API violation,
you can overwrite it
in the right folder.
So I'm going to invoke
that, and now, you
can see it's created a
values 21 folder with a file.
And I'm just going to put
Holo back in the v14 folder,
and I'm going to put
material in the v21 folder.
So now I've arranged for
this to work correctly.
But how can I be sure, right?
So now I'm going to show you
a different feature where
I can actually ask
for it to render
this layout across
different API versions.
So when I do that, you can
now see material design--
[APPLAUSE]
Right, so you can
see material design,
and you can see the
new navigation buttons,
and you can see the Holo buttons
over here, and of course,
Gingerbread without
the Action Bar
and without navigation buttons.
So another cool thing
in material design,
is that the theme lets
you actually add color.
So the way that works is
that you go into the theme,
and you can override a
couple of attributes.
So I think it's colorPrimary.
And I've already
predefined a brand color.
This can be anything.
There's actually two attributes
I want to set, color accent.
So when I sat my
own colors, which
you can see in the gutter, here,
it's a shade of blue, blueish.
When I go back, you
can see we now get
our own sort of branding.
So this new theme
makes it very easy
to add your own splash of color.
And it's not just for
text, you can see that even
the widget here is
using this color.
And more importantly, you
can even do this for bitmaps.
And the way that
works is you can
see we have a XML
drawable, here.
I've already applied at tint.
So this is what the image
looks like to begin with,
and I can apply a tint, which
is the same color resource.
You can imagine, you can
set a few color resources
in a few places and
theme the entire app.
You no longer have to
go and generate bitmaps
to get your own look.
[APPLAUSE]
So since you're going to
be working with themes,
we've added a new,
really useful, feature
to the quick documentation.
So quick reminder, quick
documentation is F1.
You know, when
you're in code, you
can just press it on a method
call to see what it does.
If you're in a
resource file, you
can press F1 to
see, for example,
all the translations
of a string.
Well, themes are
particularly useful.
So quick reminder, when you
have a resource URL that
starts with an at,
that's a normal sort
of resource reference.
When it starts with a question
mark, that's a theme look up.
It looks up the resource
in the current theme.
And look what happens when
I press F1 on this one.
Let me make this larger.
So here, it's telling me what
this resolves to, the style.
It's walking up the
style inheritance,
show me which styles
I'm picking up
for which attributes
at each level,
and resolving all of those.
I can quickly see what
text appearance medium
will look like in
the Holo theme.
So this basically makes
it a lot easier, I think,
to work with themes.
It's a bit like a DOM
inspector in web design tools.
All right, let's
look at some code.
So Studio is built
on top of IntelliJ,
and IntelliJ already has
hundreds of code inspections.
So it flags erroneous code
in your various files.
As you can see here, it's saying
there's a possible null pointer
problem, here, there's some
unused code, and so forth.
And on top of that, we've added
some Android-specific checks.
So here, for example, this
is an integer parameter,
but it's expecting an
integer resource that
represents a layout
and we're passing
string, which is clearly wrong.
So when I fix that, it's happy.
So we're making sure that
you call in the framework
correctly.
And that's all well and
good, but wouldn't it
be nice if you could
check your own code?
So now you can.
Here's a method that
I've added where
I'm taking a couple of integers,
one representing an ID,
and one representing a drawable,
and let's add some annotations
on this.
So I'm going to say
that I'm expecting
this integer represents an
ID, I'm expecting this one
to represent a drawable,
and now you can see,
it's flagging problems
in the code where
it looks like I've
flipped the parameters.
So the compiler was happy.
[APPLAUSE]
So we basically have
added some type checking
to the resource system.
And if you, basically,
build a library,
it also will export
this metadata
so that anyone
using your library
will also get the same
types of warnings.
So that's inspections.
They basically, you can
see, show up in your code
as highlights both on the
right as well as in the code.
IntelliJ also has something
called intentions,
and they're invisible, right?
So the trick to know is
that in certain places
you can press ALT,
Enter, and it'll
offer to do certain things.
For example, here
I have a string,
and it'll offer to extract
this as a string resource.
Likewise, here I have
this if statement.
Inside the if where there's
a cast, I can invoke it,
and it'll say,
hey, do you want me
to insert a declaration
with a cast here?
Or I have some nested ifs, and
I can merge those into a single,
or maybe I can split them apart.
You'll only discover
this by either
trying ALT, Enter everywhere,
or you can open the options
and there's actually an
intentions list, here.
I would like to encourage
you all to read through it
and click on each one,
it'll tell you what to do,
because you'll become a much
more productive programmer
with this editor.
You'll find that you never
have to sit and create methods.
You just write the method
call, press the right keys,
and all the sudden, you
have the method inserted.
So this is a really,
really powerful IDE
that we're building on
top of, and so you're
going to be much more
productive if you really
have to learn all
the ins outs of it.
So with that, I'm
going to turn it
back to Jamal who's going to
tell us about our future plans.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMAL EASON: So great
tour, that was great,
a lot of cool features.
So the keynote yesterday,
we talked about
and introduced the
L developer preview.
With the preview we're giving
you a set of a few extra tools
including a few tools that make
you more efficient making apps.
On the developer
tools website, you
can now download system images
for the Nexus 5 and Nexus 7.
Also, we've enabled
the Android emulator
to support Android TV and
the Nexus device simulation.
Let's switch over
to the second demo.
So in the emulator, now you can
switch between the new Leanback
experience, and as you're
developing your Android TV
apps, you can also try out the
new Leanback discovery view
as well.
So switching over to
the Nexus 5 emulator,
we also talked about
the new notifications.
And so in the
emulator, you can also
try out the new notifications.
You can swipe that away.
We've also included, inside the
emulator, the new [INAUDIBLE]
application.
And here you can see
the new material design,
the new ripple effects as well.
And lastly, we also
included a new demonstration
of the dialer.
It's on the screen?
TOR NORBYE: Bottom right.
JAMAL EASON: Where is it?
TOR NORBYE: Bottom right
JAMAL EASON: And again, you
can see the new ripple effect
on the different tabs and
columns as you move around.
And again, if you don't
have a Nexus 5, Nexus 7,
you can try the emulator.
Also you can download the
images from the website as well.
So great, let's switch
back to the slides.
So as you can see, you can try
out your new app and new design
language on the
Nexus 5 or Nexus 7,
or you can try it out
on emulator for the TV,
and for the Nexus 5.
So what's next?
So hopefully you enjoyed
what we showed you.
We showed you a
lot of great tools
and tricks from the
L developer preview.
You can also still
download Eclipse ADT,
but as you can
tell, we're spending
most of our development
effort on Android Studio.
On Android Studio, we showed
you a lot of new features
to make all your great apps
for these new form factors,
but we actually didn't show
you all the great things.
There's still more stuff
that you can actually
try out yourself.
So as far as next steps, we
talked about a number things
about the build system.
The goal is to focus on
stability and performance.
From the build back
end to the IDE,
we're looking at making
the entire development
experience faster
and more efficient.
You can check out the details
of our work in progress
on our road map on the
tools.android.com website.
As you try out Android Studio
beta and the L developer
preview, we welcome your
feedback, and please let us
know how it is.
And that's it.
For Q&A, please visit
us at the Android booth
on the second level at 10:00.
TOR NORBYE: We actually
have a few minutes.
JAMAL EASON: We have a
few minutes, I guess.
TOR NORBYE: If anyone have any
questions, come to the front.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMAL EASON: And then lastly,
leave feedback on the QR code
or with the I/O app, and
thanks again for joining us.
And we enjoy you
coming this morning.
So Q & A.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name's Connor, and I'm
at University of Washington.
And my group focuses
on accessibility,
and there's not that
many tools to develop
accessible smartphone
applications.
Are you working in
that sphere at all,
making more support in
the developer tools?
TOR NORBYE: Well,
we have some things.
So lint goes and
looks at your code
to make sure that you're
not making mistakes.
If it finds an image without
a content description,
it'll complain.
There's, I know, a lot of
support in the framework,
as well.
Beyond that, I'm not sure
if we have anything planned.
XAVIER DUCROHET: We should
definitely do something,
but I don't think we
have a lot, right now,
besides those lint checks.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: I have two things.
One is, are you planning on
supporting multiple testing
profiles?
We use Roboelectric, and
you have to kind of override
the main one, but we also
do integration testing.
And secondly, are
you going to support
testing outside of
an emulator or device
so you can run it
headless on a server?
XAVIER DUCROHET: I couldn't
quite hear all the details.
I heard Roboelectric.
AUDIENCE: OK, so
basically, are you
going to be able to support
multiple testing profiles so
that you could run both maybe
an integration test and a unit
test and have them separate.
XAVIER DUCROHET:
Yes, do want to allow
you to have-- so there's
two different things.
There's we definitely want
to help you with unit tests.
It's kind of like
difficult to-- we
want to improve the
current situation,
because we understand
that Roboelectric is not
a perfect situation.
AUDIENCE: No it's not.
XAVIER DUCROHET:
It's very difficult.
I was answering that question
in the fireside chat, yesterday.
There is pure unit
test, if you're
going to use any of
the Android APIs,
or if you link
against them, it's
very difficult to run on a VM.
There are some
things that we can
do that we're
going to try to do.
We also want to improve a
lot, like the deployment time,
because where it runs
doesn't really matter.
What you want is quick
turn around, right?
You want to be able to fix
your test, do a change,
run the test right away,
and get the results.
AUDIENCE: Right.
XAVIER DUCROHET: If we
can get that on a device,
then it should be good enough.
AUDIENCE: Well it can
also run headless,
because we've run it--
XAVIER DUCROHET: Right, so
we do also need to have--
so that's the other
part of it, right?
We also need to make sure
that on the CI server,
you can run emulators there,
start them just for that.
And we have plans
for CI features.
We just don't have them yet, but
it's our plan to do that, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my question
is about training resources.
I work at a community
college where
I teach Android programming.
And I was wondering if you
could recommend-- you know,
it's a little bit difficult.
Things are always changing,
textbooks are out of date.
If you have any
recommendations for people
who are new to Android to point
me toward certain resources.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yeah, I mean,
we're in a weird situation,
right now, where we're focusing
on Studio, but it's not 1.0.
So the current
website doesn't show
a lot of Studio
documentation, because--
TOR NORBYE: I just
read that there's
a new course being offered
that is using studio.
A bunch at Dev Rel
was working on it.
AUDIENCE: Is that
a one on Udacity?
TOR NORBYE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, OK.
I saw that just went
live I think yesterday.
JAMAL EASON: Yep.
XAVIER DUCROHET: But
we also, I think,
we have some new
documentation about Studio
going live today or
yesterday with the website.
And on our way to
1.0, we are definitely
going to improve the online
documentation too talk
more about Studio.
TOR NORBYE: And
if you can let us
know what you find
is lacking, that
would also help direct
effort in the right places.
AUDIENCE: I'd love to get
together with you guys.
Will you be at the
Android booth and be
able to talk a
little bit, so we can
talk about resources
and things like that?
TOR NORBYE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I've got
two short questions.
One is, do you plan on
adding C++ NDK support to--
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And how soon?
XAVIER DUCROHET: We are
starting to work on it.
AUDIENCE: OK, will that
include debugging support, C++?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK, great.
Second is, the import feature
from Eclipse looks really nice,
but I'm a little worried about
how the directory restructuring
is going to affect
our Git history.
Because we've got a
lot of Git history.
TOR NORBYE: Git is actually
pretty good about recognizing
file moves, because it, unlike
other version control systems,
you don't have to tell
it, I moved this to that.
It just looks at the file
content and figures out,
hey, this looks like
it corresponds to that.
So given that, there's no
other edits that it makes
to the files, other
than move them,
I'd be very surprised if
Git didn't do a good job.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yeah,
it should just work.
We're not touching the
files, so it will work.
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, we have an app,
which is multiple text files,
and some time back, we
tried to use Gradle,
but the support for building
an APK with multiple text files
was pretty limited then.
Has it changed in
the last few months?
XAVIER DUCROHET: No.
AUDIENCE: Are there any plans
to add support for that?
XAVIER DUCROHET: I think so,
but I don't know the detail,
really, but we know it's a
problem, and we're aware of it.
But I don't think we have an ETA
or announcement at this time.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
recommendations for workaround?
What can we do?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yeah, I'm not
super familiar with that part,
so I'm not sure.
But we can talk after if you
want to get into more details.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
about the BuildConfig
in your session, like
FEATURE1 false, FEATURE2
true [? or ?] something, right?
So does that work as
CP processor directives
in the [? CC++, ?] where I can
escape from the compilation
or is it on the
runtime [INAUDIBLE]?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Well, so
because it's a Boolean, right?
It a Boolean flag, Javac will
just remove that code, anyway.
So in your code, if you have
a feature, then do that,
and you compile against
a version of BuildConfig
where that particular
flags is false,
the code is going to disappear.
It's not really
preprocessor, but you
won't have unused code
in your code anyway.
AUDIENCE: Oh, that will not
be included in my build?
TOR NORBYE: Because you
make a final, right?
XAVIER DUCROHET:
Yeah, it's final.
Because it's just a constant
boolean, like a final boolean,
so it's just being removed.
AUDIENCE: Cool, hey, I'm Lisa.
I'm from Etsy.
I really like using Gradle.
It's awesome, so thanks for all
the work you guys have done.
I do have kind of a
question slash request.
Gradleware does great job on
documenting all their APIs,
so figuring out how to use
Gradle Tasks is really easy.
Do you guys have plans for
similar API documentation
for the Android plug-in?
Because right now it's been
really hard to find stuff.
XAVIER DUCROHET: We definitely--
similar to the previous answer
about training
and documentation,
things are changing
a lot, so we don't
want to spend a lot of time on
the documentation, right now.
And also, there's-- I've
seen XML plug-in using a lot
of the internal APIs.
So we still need to
figure out exactly what
will be public and non-public.
But we do want to have--
because that's the goal, right?
Is to have a really
extensible build system,
so we need to document
a lot of things.
We need to have a lot of
reference documentation.
So long term, yes.
Probably not before 1.0.
We want to improve
it, because I think
the current one is sort
of out of date, now.
So we want to improve it.
TOR NORBYE: But we do
have a Google group
where you can basically
ask about things.
So if something isn't
clear, it might not
be just lack of documentation.
It might be unintuitive
API we should fix.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sometimes
it's hard to see
when you do changes to the API.
You have to know to follow
the right group in G+ or be
on the mailing list.
TOR NORBYE: We're hoping to
stop breaking everybody--
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yeah, that's
the goal of beta, right?
It's to be more stable.
I mean there are some unintended
breakage when we realized
that people are using API maybe
they shouldn't, so we can't do
much about that, but
the public API, I think,
are more stable now.
And we deprecate
rather than break them,
so we can start
documenting them.
TOR NORBYE: So I'm sorry,
we're basically out of time.
So we're going to go to the
booth on the second floor.
So if you have questions,
please join us there.
Thank you everyone.